hello everybody I'm Fred here hello
everybody I'm Legolas and this is
sibling rivalry
shouldn't you be Sam Holmes now behind
you the world is ahead
actually we're planning on not doing
this again until after the new year cuz
we're gonna like build a little sad and
have all sorts of bells and whistles
giant robots with lasers do not need it
but it'll look cool
that's his budget anyway is so
unfortunately or fortunately depending
on how you like the movie The Hobbit
came out so we kind of have to talk
about that and I know we can I'm just
gonna say this is an impromptu episode
so this is not like a big episode of
sibling rivalry with all the bells and
whistles we're kind of just doing this
for fun and this is vivan style but we
just felt we had to talk about it
because it is the movie of the year
unless you believe all that hype about
lame is but I now probably the next
review because we're probably good
disagree yeah yeah we like that way miss
so we're probably we're probably going
to we're probably going to do one for
that as well but the next couple
episodes while we're uh you know getting
stuff set for a relaunch is just gonna
be fun and impromptu so yeah we saw the
Hobbit and uh I don't know Doug what did
you okay well so in my opinion I'm gonna
be a minority on this but I don't give a
fuck uh personally this is my favorite
of the Lord the Rings movies which I
know sounds insane like it are you
serious yes okay no but here's why No
okay okay now first of all we should
talk a little bit about what is it's a
much smaller story than the Earl or the
Rings I mean you're not gonna see big
epic Bell get some how much longer that
is a little odd just a touch to be fair
having only read one of the Tokyo Sally
read fellowship but I know I know there
are stories for me this is the Lord the
Rings movie I always want to see okay
first let's talk about the fact that it
actually the camera actually stays the
fuck still and it act and I know it
sounds like 2:49 impaired
kids of topic here you think Jacques and
Pierre here AG partner be like oh why
isn't it zooming around why is it even
looking really pretty you're really
threatening and and why are there shots
of Gandil Singh keep it secret keep it
safe or bamboo killing I should have
done this a long time ago or Elijah what
going straighter you know those really
obnoxious close-ups that can't just let
a scene play this movie finally in my
opinion lets characters breathe and it
actually lets a scene just play out and
to me it feels like the first time it
feels like the first time you can
actually breathe in this world this
world felt believable okay I give you
that it didn't you felt like you could
breathe in this world and you weren't
being breathed on but that's very good
way of putting away a close-up or not or
keeping the camera still does not like
characters make okay well that has
nothing to say I'm glad they slowed the
camera down that's fine they slowed
every scene down too though like but to
a snail's pace but but I I I like that
in this movie because again it gave
unlike the other movies I do like the
other movies I don't get that right I do
like them but it always felt like okay
well now we have to go over here and do
this well now we have to go over here
and do this on it and I understand that
it's supposed to be an action feel it's
supposed to be you know the castles and
the armies say stuff like that things
happen I don't know if I it's supposed
to start off simple and I never felt it
did start off simple that's what I like
about this what it did at the Grand
backstory which was it cool that
backstory started off simple no the
banks trying to read The Hobbit I would
have been thoroughly confused I was like
I haven't read the eyeball define here's
12 dwarves here's this is Thorin son of
a gun son of Mickey Fran Oh Thailand
Sunday you know and his great father
grandmother's killed by as a man I was
before small came and attacked Arab are
like I was sitting there I was like I've
read The Hobbit a number of times I'm
like I would be lost
III never the hot eye follows it find
the only thing I couldn't understand is
what the hell does a dragon want with
gold that's the only thing I don't
understand
freak and drag it just drag his want
gold they need their bling um but really
if you're looking for any more
explanation about
it's not gonna provide it I was pretty
much is he well well I think that's part
of the problem okay that's part of the
problem of the movie it's a children's
story it's meant for kids you know what
you set yourself up right there because
if this is the Lord of the Rings movie I
wanted this isn't Lord of the Rings it's
not it was never meant to be like this
he didn't write it like this it was not
meant to be this big giant epic it is a
kids tale a yarn where a wizard and
twelve dwarves and a little tiny man go
save some gold from a dragon and there
are goblins and elves and big giant bear
people and trolls with cockney accent
but you know that they would not be able
to get away with that if they want to
tell the story
like how Tolkien originally told it
which was very simple we didn't don't
make it I first again for someone who
did not read the book I know the basic
premise by I did not read the book not
only could I follow it very well but I
also actually intrigued say like with
the the dwarves and the elves with why
that prejudice was there this movie
shows why that prejudice was there I
found that really fascinating how the
elves did not come and help them in the
beginning that's fine there's there's
some things that Jackson does right and
I'm gonna be thumping on Jackson and
this is going to turn into probably a
long hour sized rant but we would go
Noah Antoine your essence oh yeah this
is gonna be like a Noah v-log um there
are things that Jackson did right in
this film and there are things that he
does perfectly in this film um but it's
a matter of tone there is no consistent
tone in this film I I thought there was
who okay who is this film made for it's
made for a fans of The Lord of Rings
movies I would actually argue it's
probably not made for fans of the
original book from what I understand
about it but if you're making something
for fans of the Lord of the Rings movie
you have a giant Phantom Menace style
goblin king with the giant jowls I kept
my ballsack chin yeah the ball section
sitting there you know I kept wanting to
go
we said well hey that guy was awesome
come I like that
no I mean here's the thing if you were
making a kid's film yes if you're making
a kid's film one second we have trolls
with cockney accent what are we gonna do
how we going to eat them enough we have
you know the freaking goblin gang moved
our duty we're going to sing the song
and then ten seconds later there are
these hideously looking orcs chopping
heads off like there is no time it is
whatsoever not for kids and no they're
gonna see that when they see lower the
ratings anymore the Rings now I mean
like I say I don't expect my gonna die
then why did I have okay fine so and
this is my problem if I wanted to see a
Lord of the Rings movie that's fine you
can make it like a Lord of the Rings
movie I have no problem with that then
make it like a Lord of the Rings movie I
don't want to sit there and watch some
troll blow snot all over Bilbo or
freakin bad dwarf humor or a bunch of
dwarves belching into a jar or whatever
those things are for kids you saw that
in the other films though tell me all
the time not only didn't knowledge or
Gerardo like Legolas riding the
skateboard shield down and stuff like
that nobody taught you so tort that is
isn't in rap for readily stupidly
awesome when it came to Lego come on no
it's open no actually I completely agree
with you those were the things I hated
about the Lord of the Rings movies I
know it's the lore the Rings move no but
this is way worse cuz now you've got
okay who is the weakest character in The
Lord of the Rings films the week ahead
probably giveaway Gimli who do we have
in this movie my 12 giveaways well Gimli
except for the one clip Thorin and
Balan's balance pretty balanced not too
bad I bet I take it back a little bit
actually this is the one thing I will
also say it is a weakness we're in this
film I really thought you know we got to
know a lot of these uh lights that these
people seem a little bit more believable
incredible except for the majority of
dwarves except majority the dwarves who
just also to blend into one Gimli with
the exception of a cop which is a
problem is a problem because the book is
at about four or five dwarves it had
pretty clear personalities and the rest
have silly names I would have liked if
they gave them a little bit more
personality or just be one helping carry
doc yeah you know the rest is kind of
boiling it I mean even then the the
funniest thing is somebody was telling
me they're like well they did that cheap
we're just all of the dwarves just
tumbling at once and they're just like
and the rest and like the book did that
oh the book pretty much had that app it
was like and then there were these other
dwarves
so but that's my problem it's just like
if you're going to do this then you have
to change the book in such a way then it
makes the film better and it didn't it
actually made it worse things he should
have changed he didn't and things that
were necessary through and I don't need
to see Saruman and Galadriel having this
big like debate at a roundtable the
movie just ground to a halt it's not
like fellowship or at least it's like
we're going to decide the fate of
mankind no it's us weird guy says
there's like this necromancer somewhere
and that's it well obviously yes but
even this isn't will the senator yield
it's ridiculous first of all we did have
that Fellowship of the Ring anyway it's
exactly what you just said where
everyone started to it's like giving
this thing except it meant something it
could take it to say and they and that
team did have a purpose I guess a
distraction for the doors elite no yes
no here's the major difference that's
seen in Rivendell in Fellowship of the
Ring set up two more movies what did
this scene do in this film it allowed
the doors to escape and violent no I
think you could also say oh yeah but
here's what I liked about that scene too
is that it finally allowed us and this
always bother me at least in the movies
uh the book I think they explain a
little bit more but sorrow man from the
minute you see this fucker and his giant
evil castle that Bowser with living you
say that's a bad guy I like for once you
actually see him having a conversation
you know like having them meet up and
you can see oh how these people were
friends and how they talked and stuff
that would be great in the extended
edition DVD then just sitting there this
is the explain Edition that Nikki wants
to see no and this is where Jackson got
it right he's like you know I'm making a
movie here I am NOT making something
that is entirely for Tolkien purus I'm
sorry I love talking I have read The
Silmarillion thrice I use words like
price there is so no that this is where
I'm coming from any of you guys on the
message bars it's like you just don't
understand
no no I do I have the history of
middle-earth like Christopher Tolkien's
books talking about how the books were
written it's about how the books were
written I own them I've read them twice
so don't give me that I am telling you
straight up there is too much talking in
this movie there are too many side
quests side stories it's like I'm
playing a game of Skyrim in the movie
theater it's like you're going one way
and then you plant like Skyrim and they
like those worlds failing like Skyrim
because they can choose what quest they
want to go on if a question looks boring
I can be like delete fake I can be like
I will ignore this quest and go on my
own and do something else I when you try
to make a narrative that goes from point
A to point B you just can't get
sidetracked like that or you have to
construct your narrative in a better way
I know you're just like I'm so glad that
they spend time in Hobbiton they needed
to get that hell on the road for Toni's
that the lore of the Rings movies
actually went from A to B the the
trilogy went from A to B with no
diversions no sidetracking at all I'm
saying the original director's cut did
it better than the extended edition and
I'm okay with that because the extended
edition is for the purists for the fans
or for people were just like you know
what I want more sitting in the movie
theater and watching the extent of the
dish and later I'm like I know why most
of these scenes were cut some I would
have preferred there but the bulk of
them I'm like you know what no this was
not absolutely necessary to telling your
base story
okay just wasn't you say this you asked
why is this movie made they should have
made this movie and you're saying well
then this movie is only for purest of
Tolkien why can't it just be for purist
of talking them fine that's not me I'm
not of your violence that does not make
it a good movie though that makes it a
great fanfic a great fan interpretation
uh you know it would make a great
miniseries like I was looking at this I
was like obviously what Peter Jackson
just wanted to do was make an HBO style
miniseries you could divide this up into
nine to twelve episodes and it would
work because you have the ability after
an hour to pause and say hey or wait
till next week I reread that entire
section where they got up to in the
movies there are more minutes in the
movie than there are pages in the book
for the first how do you do that how is
that physically possible they take their
time and have the character no likable I
know and they got stuff there probably
necessary yeah they add a ton of things
from the appendices that had nothing to
do with the story that Tolkien admitted
was not necessary to the story okay let
me tell you this talking in 1960 decided
to rewrite the Hobbit he's like he was
he looked at Lord of the Rings he looked
at the humming zag you know what I wrote
this as a story for my child by the way
what is a children's story what is a
bedtime story what's it supposed to be
to put your kids to sleep well that this
film does great according to you doesn't
well I just great if that's what you
want but I don't want that from my movie
so and he decided he's like you know
what they don't sync up he's like this
is not working I will rewrite the Hobbit
so matches Lord of the Rings he got like
a quarter of the way through it and he's
like I can't do this he's like people
are complaining and rightfully so this
is in The Hobbit what was this cute
little kids story now just is something
else entirely so that's my problem you
either have to go all out and say I am
doing a kid's film like the original
story or I am doing this like Lord of
the Rings as it stands it's too messy
and too much humor aimed at kids and I'm
sorry it is way worse than Lord of the
Rings was why is it dumb moments don't I
on moments it I don't remember
trolls snorting all over hobbits and
like this just got really low brow and
the kids loved it then for entire 20
minutes stretches you wonder what
happened while I was in the cinema I had
kids talking and kicking the back um I
see you want to know why cuz they don't
give a crap who thorns fathers that's
why and they don't give a rabbi about
sermon talking to Gandalf about I know
the dwarves are going this present oh
the necromancer is I'm gonna read it how
do we know if this is the ball ghoul
Brit but all the Phil
have had a mix I mean this is sort of
the upside downside of what Peter
Jackson has to do it has to appeal to so
many people has to appeal to the fans
allure the Rings it has to appeal to
adult has to appeal to children it has
to get that teenage Democrat band to get
people I guess you get people into
fantasy and I thought for the most part
the lure the Rings I think it's a
buttered mess but I like it I think it
works out the constants so much better
in my not just so much nicer but I don't
think and I I know I get it I've set
their message boards when people to take
the elves burnett helms deep and that
within our when i would carve indelicate
i don't care you have to write a
narrative that goes from one point to
another and if you have moments from the
book that are just like this is just
unfilmable or this does not serve the
main plot you reconstruct it and he
reconstructed so much in Lord of the
Rings that actually made the story
better from a cinematic perspective he
did little of that here
radagast isn't this he's the other he's
the third wizard that was mentioned in
the appendices Gandalf mentions one
weird
that was weird all I can tell you is
from reading the books and the little
entries about him I got this image of
like a hermit a st. Francis of Assisi
type who likes animals who is a little
odd but you know still kind of together
and still a wizard that make a little
too goofy is it we're not in Jar Jar
Binks territory but I swear to God when
they brought out the rabbit sled I can
tell you that even Toki that is most
like juvenile moments in The Hobbit I
don't think would have been like slid of
rabbits
I don't what was that in the book then
the rabbit sled
I do not know cuz red and gas wasn't in
it
uh I mean art just anything was never
said they had a rabbit so I cuz my
living I know that was silly I was
really I don't remember that at all okay
okay let's put this way for a film I
mean I think we can both agree the first
film is a you know first time first book
is a children's book and it was written
for children it's written very simply
there's a ton of stuff that does not add
up like how come trolls in the air lor
the Rings can talk you know what the
hell is a dragon want with gold and I
mean this is clearly stuff that for a
kids book you know uh but I think I
can't know much for
know that you're probably right does not
need to exist I think it's very well
done and I think it captures some I
think it would have been like that I
said that those other fields could not
capture I then would have been very well
done if it were like to our shirt okay
let me think this way if this film ended
and I knew there was only one film left
and we were at the halfway point in the
story I would probably be more forgiving
Jesus Christ through a German opera is
better shorter than this thing and those
things are like four or five days okay
do you like did you like when all the
doors sang the song of the song that's
in the trailer I did okay what was the
point you could cut that woulda missed a
thing I think it added atmosphere to the
scene exactly that's what the other
stuff does too it adds atmosphere it
allows these characters to be characters
that you can like it in wine watch them
other jerk it's the same problem I have
a Fantasia 2000 which is any one of
those individual bits and scenes from
Fantasia 2000 it's fun Oh whales fine oh
when you add them up together they all
add up to something that's just like
this is all kind of more the same and
you needed to cut it down and pick your
best moments okay so we've rambled for a
pretty long time here you know just
talking about what wilayah Dada da let's
people live here stuff I say just
last-minute thoughts anything else you
want to say about the movie - final
thoughts on the film this was I'll give
you two films like I'll see if you want
do two films I get it you want to flesh
out appendices fine you got to do it
right this should have been two films at
two and a half hours each tops that's
tops probably could have done this in
two hours each um he did so Peter
Jackson's it's just a great job of
finding a coherent narrative where come
on Tolkien Pyrrhus let's be honest there
was none um in Lord of the Rings and he
just can't do it here um he things that
he didn't need to be there that we're
from the appendices are there I get the
stuff of the necromancer I won't spoil
it for you guys that haven't read the
books of the appendices or whatever but
yes there is sort of a point but you
have to find a way to do it right and
mesh with the narrative and as it stands
in this film it's a giant detour and an
hour and a half to get to chapter two I
mean that's all I can say for a book
that is just it's a light read like you
just do
not need to do this it's like taking
Mary Poppins and turning it into this
like eight hour long epic like it is the
Broadway version Joe well imagine three
Broadway versions then you got it it's
like you know this should have been a
fun little thing and he does get a
number of things right and the acting is
great I'd say even better than in some
cases then even the other films
particularly Gandalf is a little nicer
and you know but yeah it's just so long
when it just didn't need to be much like
this rant so I got bored by this rant I
know I felt uh as you right now I really
enjoyed it um for the reasons that
actually a lot of which he listed I do
like the length because it allowed allow
characters to breathe I felt like I can
know these people better a lot of
performances to shine through allow me
to feel like I could breathe in this
world and for me that's always what I
think talking is about it is about
living in these worlds um and a lot of
stuff I do agree with as well it's not
as big a film it's not as driven by
story and there are a lot of detours but
for someone that if you love that world
and you want to be in that world uh I
say you'll probably like this film I
think I will be a minority of the one
that likes this one the most out of the
others and I will agree I don't know how
they're gonna make two other films out
of this either um but you know what I'll
wait and see what they have in store and
hopefully it'll be good stuff I really
liked it what would you say go see it I
if you're a fan on Lord of rings I would
see it once but I mean as somebody who's
a die-hard Lord of the Rings fan that's
saying something for me I'm like you can
see it once and probably be satisfied
and I saw it in twenty eight frames per
second so I have no idea this is great
debate is it better to see it in 48
frames per second or scrub your eyes out
with steel wool like but I I just saw it
in the normal version and it will crisp
and good but like the the effects the
resolution was so high on the CGI
effects in particular I can only imagine
it's going to be worse with the higher
framerate so um yeah and I think you
know you know what I think of it you
know
what I enjoy and you can probably get a
grasp of if that's what you would enjoy
as well so I don't disagree with him in
theory I'm just saying you got to pace
your film right you can totally let
characters breathe but you need to have
some sort of momentum and you need to
have some sense of story from a short
story like when you take a short story
and you pace it wrong and you make it
six hours long there's there's no real
excuse for that
so well I liked it so until you know I
won't everybody's entitled to their own
opinion so just it's subjective and
you're wrong I'm the Walker and he was
an ass and he's wrong but he's still an
ass and I'm right